Before we get started,
be sure you're using a yarn that's
the appropriate weight for your machine.
Just be sure you're using a medium weight
yarn that fits in the
hooks of the needles.
Do you need yarn on cones
for Machine knitting?
No.
All you need is to have the yarn wound
in a way that it will easily
feed into the machine.
Often you can use a center-pull ball
from a yarn manufacturer.
Some knitters will use a ball winder
and rewind everything, skeins,
hanks balls, everything.
If your ball winder creates a flat bottom
ball, you can also use the yarn
from the outside of the ball.
Do whatever works for you.
You don't want to spend a whole lot
of time dealing with knots
as you're knitting.